eine fabrikruine überwuchert von dichtem
wald
ohne sie wäre hitlers rüstungsindustrie
kollabiert
ein gigantischer turm in portimao der
ein inferno überstand
die mauern sind unglaublich robust
gebaut viel zu dick man hatte angst dass
stürme ihn einreichen könnten
ein verlassener leuchtturm der von den
elementen verschlungen wird
es sieht beklemmend aus denn das was
dort einmal stand ist jetzt einfach weg
[Musik]
und ein bizarrer kuppelbau der vom
höhepunkt des kalten krieges erzählt
das war wie ein gestreckte mittelfinger
mitten ins gesicht der sowjets
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
die anlagen aufgegeben manche sind heute
lebensgefährlich versorgt wer hat sie
errichtet und wie und warum wurden sie
aufgegeben
[Musik]
an der polnischen ostseeküste nahe der
stadtpolizei liegt ein sperrgebiet
mitten im wald
[Musik]
auf dem fast zwei quadratkilometer
großen gelände stehen zerbombte ruinen
skelette aus stahl beton unter denen
sich ein netzwerk aus unterirdischen
bunkern und tunneln verwirrt
erstreckt sich ein beton labyrinth man
erkennt noch gut dass diesmal eine
fabrikanlage war
so etwas baut man nicht über nacht das
kostet enorm viel zeit und geld
von der riesigen anlage zeugen nur noch
betriebe die aus dem wald tragen
daneben ton hohe blöcke die ein düsteres
geheimnis bergen
[Applaus]
wer genau hinsieht findet hinweise auf
den zweck dieser fabrik
an einem gebäude steht auf deutsch
geschrieben
kohlebunker 4 und ein stückchen weiter
finden sich überreste großer tanz
in zwei hinweise die eine zum kern der
geschichte führen
zu welchem zweck wurde diese anlage
gebaut was ist auf dem gelände passiert
und warum wurde die fabrik aufgegeben
in den 1930 er jahren heißt polizei noch
pölitz und gehört zum deutschen reich
für die kriegspläne von adolf hitler
spielte ort eine ganz besondere rolle
die nazis rüsten seit der machtübernahme
wieder heimlich auf
1935 wird offiziell die gründung der
wehrmacht verkündet die neuen
streitkräfte haben allerdings ein großes
problem
deutschland hatte eigentlich nicht genug
rohstoffe für einen krieg
außer kohle und wasser mussten fast alle
bodenschätze importiert werden
bei hitlers kriegsvorbereitungen spielte
dieser mangel eine wichtige rolle
besonders heikel ist die versorgung mit
treibstoff
ohne benzin und diese kann kein einziges
flugzeug abheben kein schlachtschiff in
see stechen und kein panzer rollen
die deutschen hatten bei vielen
operationen betreib stoff mangel zu
kämpfen das wichtigste transportmittel
für die wehrmacht im zweiten weltkrieg
war tatsächlich der pferde wagen
deutschland muss einen großen teil
seines treibstoffs importieren um
unabhängiger von handelspartnern zu sein
wollen die nazis ihren sprit selbst
herstellen
in sogenannten hydro werken soll aus
kohle benzin werden
im wald bei kühlungsborn die nazis eine
gigantische anlage die kosten dafür sind
immens
es ist keine normale raffinerie durch
ein neuartiges verfahren wird kohle
verflüssigt und daraus dann flugbenzin
synthetisiert
[Musik]
mit dieser methode stellten die
deutschen ab den 20er jahren bis mitte
des jahrhunderts aus kohle benzin
wirklich gutes benzin sehr rein aber
auch unfassbar teuer
[Musik]
für die produktion wird zunächst ein
brei aus fein gemahlener kohle und
schweröl an gemischt
zusammen mit wasserstoff und einem
katalysator wird die masse dann auf rund
450 grad celsius erhitzt bei einem druck
von 700 bar ein aufwendiges und
kostspieliges verfahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genomik sowie wirtschaftlich rechnet
sich das überhaupt
für eine tonne synthetischen benzins
braucht man sechs tonnen kohle plus die
kohle um das alles zu transportieren
hitler fand das für nazi-deutschland
vielleicht sinnvoll in jeder anderen
volkswirtschaft würde man sagen das
lohnt sich nicht
1940 gehen die hüttenwerke pölitz in
betrieb
im zentrum der anlage steht der bunker
mit der mühle für die kohle brocken um
mich herum stehen die eigentlichen hydra
anlagen der kessel und destillate sowie
zahlreiche tank kessel darin wird das
synthetisierte benzin gelagert und über
pipelines zu güterzügen transportiert
die nazis brauchen den sprit aus pönitz
dringend für die operation barbarossa
im juni 1941 überfällt hitlers wehrmacht
die sowjetunion
der angriff verschlingt enorme mengen
treibstoff
1943 produziert allein pölitz 700.000
tonnen benzin
insgesamt betreiben die nazis rund 12
der synthetische benzin hier ist die
deutsche kriegsmaschinerie am laufen das
war die einzige verlässliche treibstoff
quelle deswegen waren sie ziemlich
abhängig von den werken
ohne sie wäre hitlers rüstungsindustrie
wohl zusammengebrochen
die aufwendige produktion kostet nicht
nur geld sondern auch viele leben in den
hüttenwerken schuften zwangsarbeiter und
kz-häftlinge
30.000 menschen aus den besatzungs
gebieten in ost und westeuropa werden
nach böhles verschleppt
fast die hälfte von ihnen stirbt manche
fallen den brutalen fabrik auf sören zum
opfer andere den giftigen und
brandgefährlichen arbeitsbedingungen
allein in görlitz kamen 13.000 zwei
arbeiter ums leben das sollte man nie
vergessen
als sich das blatt wendet und die
alliierten die oberhand gewinnen wird
die versorgung mit synthetischen benzin
aus anlagen wie pellets immer wichtiger
[Musik]
germans die deutschen waren abhängig von
synthetischem benzin ein angriff auf die
hydra werke hätte dramatische folgen für
den nachschub gehabt es hätte zb kein
flugbenzin mehr gegeben um sie so an
auszubilden es wären immer mehr
flugzeuge gebaut worden aber ohne benzin
hätten sie ihnen nichts genützt
[Musik]
jetzt zeigt sich die schwachstelle bei
der herstellung von synthetischem benzin
ohne kohle läuft nichts in den
hüttenwerken aber auch nicht in den
anderen fabriken auch kraftwerke und
schiffe brauchen kohle ebenso wie die
züge die den treibstoff aus pellets
abtransportieren sollen
die deutsche luftwaffe muss für einen
liter kerosin viel mehr ressourcen
aufwenden als die briten amerikaner oder
russen
die kriegskosten sind um ein vielfaches
höher für die deutschen weil ihnen die
wichtigsten ressourcen fehlen
[Musik]
ende 1944 rücktritts in die reichweite
von alliierten kampfbombern im januar
1945 starten sie einen ebenso kurzen wie
schlagkräftigen angriff gegen das
hüttenwerk
innerhalb von 14 minuten gegen 1600
bomben auf die anlage nieder für die
kriegsmaschine der nazis ist es ein
vernichtender schlag
[Musik]
im verlauf der offensive gingen die
treibstoffreserven der deutschen
dramatisch zurück und das hat sich
natürlich stark auf die
einsatzbereitschaft ausgewirkt
im februar 1945 nähert sich die rote
armee köniz die deutschen ingenieure und
chemiker fliehen richtung westen
[Musik]
zurück bleiben die ruinen der einstigen
hightech anlage heute kann man ihre
überreste besichtigen sie sind das
monument einer technologie die im
dritten reich rückgrat und achillesferse
zugleich war
[Musik]
die alliierten wollten die
treibstoffproduktion in allen mitteln
stoppen die spielen davon kann man es
heute noch überall sehen bombenkrater im
boden ruinen der zerstörten gebäude
manche von ihnen wurden abgerissen die
alliierten schlugen mit ganzer härte zu
weil sie wussten dass sie nazi
deutschland damit in die knie zwingen
konnte
könig erinnert an das grauen von
zwangsarbeit und tod im zweiten
weltkrieg
und es ist eine erinnerung daran dass
den nazis jedes mittel recht war um
treibstoff herzustellen wo es keinen gab
[Musik]
gut 6000 kilometer von polizei entfernt
im us-bundesstaat maryland ragt ein
imposantes bauwerk in die höhe
der massive turm mitten im herzen von
bobby moore ist nicht zu übersehen er
gilt als ein wahrzeichen der stadt aber
nur wenige kennen seine geschichte
wenn man durch portimao fährt und ihn
sieht freut man sich dass ein
fabrikschornsteine
kraftwerk oder vielleicht ein lagerhaus
das war mal das höchste gebäude der usa
komplett aus ziegelsteinen gebaut einer
unmenge von ziegelsteinen
der turm ragt rund 65 meter hoch nur ein
paar kleine fenster durchbrechen die
mehr als einen meter dicken mauern wie
schießscharten
durch eine schwere eisentür am fuß des
turms gelangt man in einen hohlen
schacht
jackson firmen folie kennt den turm wie
kaum ein anderer der historiker kümmert
sich um die instandhaltung der
historischen gebäude von mortimer
hier muss man ganz schön kletter 65
meter das sind gut 13 14 stockwerken
es ist wirklich ein meisterhaftes
bauwerk damals ein absolutes no go
[Musik]
holzbalken ragen ins dunkel des schachts
sie sind die rahmenkonstruktion für ein
bizarres zickzack gebilde aus eisen
ein wackliger treppen rundlauf führt in
einer spirale nach oben
[Musik]
auf den wänden aus gebrannten ziegeln
sind reste von glattem putz zu sehen
nur kenner können in dem vertrackten
holz konstrukt einen hinweis auf den
zweck des turms erkennen
wozu diente dieses riesige bauwerk und
warum wurde es aufgegeben
[Musik]
1812 nur ein paar jahrzehnte nach dem
amerikanischen unabhängigkeitskrieg sind
die vereinigten staaten wieder im
konflikt mit ihrer früheren
kolonialmacht großbritannien
die briten setzten sogar das weiße haus
in brand die amerikaner haben allerdings
noch keine nennenswerte
rüstungsindustrie sie sind auf
waffenimporte aus frankreich holland und
spanien angewiesen vor allem die knappe
munition wird zum problem
die usa waren damals noch eine ziemlich
junge nation sie wollten sich auf der
weltbühne behaupten und dafür mussten
sie schnell einen weg finden selbst
günstig munition herzustellen
[Musik]
1828 legt charles carroll der dritte
einer der unterzeichner der
unabhängigkeitserklärung den grundstein
für den phönix munition strom
eine vertikale fabrik für gewehr und
musketen kugeln aus blei
100.000 säcke munition werden hier pro
jahr hergestellt jeder sack wiegt 25
pfund
für den bau des turms werden rund eine
million ziegelsteine gebraucht das ist
nicht nur eine logistische
herausforderung
man konnte nicht unbegrenzt in die höhe
bauen denn durch das gewicht der steiner
entsteht ein fuß des turms ein so
immenser druck dass die ziegel
irgendwann einfach bersten
[Musik]
der turm nimmt dennoch
schwindelerregende ausmaße an meter für
meter wächst der schacht in die höhe
eine wichtige voraussetzung um hier
munition fertigen zu können
zu der zeit schoss man noch mit
richtigen bleikugeln und solche runden
projektile stellte man damals am besten
her indem man geschmolzenes blei aus
großer höhe in die tiefe goss die
tropfen nehmen im fallen eine fast
perfekte kugel formen an
der brite williams hat das verfahren
1782 erfunden und ließ noch im selben
jahr den ersten schritt turm der welt
bauen
nach den gesetzen der physik entstehen
darin nahezu perfekte schrotkugeln
dafür wird tonnenweise blei an die
spitze des turms gehievt und bei fast
330 grad celsius zum schmelzen gebracht
das flüssige blei wird dann durch ein
kupfer sieht gegossen die
oberflächenspannung und der
luftwiderstand beim fallen machen aus
denen blei tropfen runde schrotkugeln am
grund des turms wartet ein wasserbecken
zum abkühlen
man nutzt einfach die schwerkraft um
kugeln zu formen ziemlich genial aber
dafür braucht man natürlich eine enorme
fallhöhe die bietet zum beispiel ein
monströser turm wie dieser
einen 65 meter hohen turm zu bauen ist
damals eine echte herausforderung
die erbauer wussten gar nicht worauf sie
sich da eingelassen hatten
[Musik]
es ist unfassbar
die haben das ganze ding ohne gerüst
gebaut einfach lage für lage schön
langsam immer weiter die mauern sind
unglaublich robust und eigentlich viel
zu deckt man hatte angst dass stürme
oder andere naturkatastrophen den turm
ein reißen könnten deswegen steht er
heute noch wie ein fels
ohne baugerüst an so einem team zu
arbeiten ist lebensgefährlich schutz
soll eine raffinierte und einzigartige
konstruktion bieten
die leute fragen mich oft was das für
gusseiserne schienen da sind es ist eine
art aufzug bremssystem eine frühe
version davon
man hat nicht einfach einem seilzug
eingebaut denn was passiert wenn das
tragseil reißt
bei einem schrecklichen unfall waren
arbeiter in die tiefe gestürzt zum glück
überlebten sie danach wurden zur
sicherheit diese schienen eingebaut der
aufzug corp hatte metall sportlern in
seinem genau in die führung passen falls
eintrag cyrus glitter corp langsam über
die zick zack schiene nach unten
hoffentlich ohne dass jemand verletzt
wurde
1828 ein jahr nach der grundsteinlegung
nimmt der phoenix schock trauer die
produktion auf
das war damals vermutlich die
effizienteste munitions anlage der usa
in dieser fabrik wurden hunderttausende
säcke gewährt region hergestellt
gut 30 jahren fährt der phoenix schotter
drei kugeln für musketen und
schrotflinten
dann setzt sich eine neue verbesserte
art von munition durch
die konisch geformten patronen
versprechen eine viel bessere reichweite
und treffgenauigkeit
den schrecklichen beweis liefern sie auf
den schlachtfeldern des amerikanischen
bürgerkriegs zwischen nord und
südstaaten
für die rüstungsindustrie spielt der
sturm von bobby moore bald keine rolle
mehr
stattdessen wird in der vertikalen
fabrik jagdmunition hergestellt
1878 kommt es dann zu einem
folgenschweren unfall
die holzkonstruktion im schacht fängt
feuer
die flammen die aus dem traum schlugen
konnte man kilometerweit sehen die
ganzen holzbalken im inneren brannten
aber den ziegelmauern überstanden das
entfernung ohne große schäden
[Musik]
ziegel sind gute isolatoren sie werden
nicht so schnell heiß oder kalt
die dicken mauern leiten die wärme
schlecht weiter
keine trade und ziegelsteine werden ja
bei viel höheren temperaturen gebrannt
als bei einem holzfeuer entstehen
der turm erhebt sich aus der asche wie
sein namensgeber phoenix
und einen monat nachdem hand laufen die
geschäfte wieder
über den fortschritt kann sich das
massive bollwerk auf dauer nicht
widersetzen ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts setzten sich endgültig
effizientere methoden zur munitions
herstellung durch
tonnenweise blei in die höhe zu hieven
gilt nun als zu kostspielig und
gefährlich
1892 schließt der phoenix shop power
seiner eisernen fort
[Musik]
heute erinnert der tormann eine zeit
großer umbrüche in der die usa ihre
politische und militärische
unabhängigkeit erlangten
beinahe wäre dieses denkmal jedoch dem
erdboden gleichgemacht worden
[Musik]
eine öl und gasfirma hatte den ton
gekauft und plante ihn abzureißen
die menschen in baltimore liebten ihr
wahrzeichen aber so sehr dass sie sich
zusammentaten und geld sammelten sie
kauften den turm selbst und schenken
ihnen der stadt mit der auflage ihn zu
bewahren
heute steht der turm besuchern als
museum offen
ein denkmal das von den anfängen der
rüstungsindustrie in den usa erzielt
heute gehört das land zu den größten
waffen herstellern der welt
[Musik]
zurück auf die andere seite des
atlantiks nach berlin aus dem wald am
rande der bundeshauptstadt fragt eine
bizarre aussehende ruine
auf dem teufelsberg thront ein gebilde
das an eine verlassene raumstation
erinnert
den ersten blick wüsste ich nicht was
das sein soll aber schön ist
von weitem könnte man es beinahe für ein
altes preußisches schloss halten aber
dann entpuppt es sich plötzlich als
bizarre moderne anlage die auf diesem
hügel mit blick über ganz berlin steht
der hauptturm ragt rund 80 meter hoch
über das teufelswerk plateau
auf seiner spitze thront eine gewaltige
kuppel
zwei weitere kuppeln flankieren den bau
und ein paar meter daneben steht noch
ein tor
durch zerfetzte plastikplanen kann man
einen blick ins innere der kugeln werfen
die ganze anlage ist verfallen
[Musik]
ein absolutes mekka für
verschwörungstheoretiker
freigeister und natürlich
der ort versprüht eine ganz besondere
atmosphäre
welchen zweck diente die anlage und
warum wurde sie aufgegeben
in den 60er jahren ist berlin ein
brennpunkt im kalten krieg die stadt ist
seit dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs in
vier sektoren aufgeteilt drei davon
werden von den westalliierten
kontrolliert den usa großbritannien und
frankreich
der ostteil der stadt steht unter
sowjetischer verwaltung
mitten im sozialistischen ostblock liegt
west berlin wie eine insel ein perfektes
ziel für spione
[Musik]
die amerikanische botschaft in moskau
war vollgestopft mit abhörtechnik die us
flotte wurde permanent überwacht von
sowjetischen fischerbooten mit spionage
ausrüstung an bord
alle haben sich gegenseitig bespitzelt
die exponierte insellage west berlins
bietet den westalliierten eine einmalige
chance der us nachrichtendienst nsa bord
eine hightech radarstation den sowjets
genau vor die nase
amerikaner und briten nennen die
abhöranlage schlicht den hügel
[Musik]
am rand des sowjetischen gebiets waren
überall horchposten mit riesigen
antennen sie den elektronischen
nachrichtenverkehr empfingen und diese
besondere abholstation lag einfach
perfekt rund 200 kilometer hinter den
feindlichen linien in der in klasse west
berlin
vom teufelsberg aus konnte der westen
die kommunikation der sowjetischen
streitkräfte lauschen
[Musik]
1962 kommt es zwischen den usa und der
sowjetunion beinahe zur direkten
konfrontation
die kuba krise bringt die welt an den
rand eines atomkriegs im jahr darauf
beginnt die nse mit dem bau ihrer abhör
station auf dem teufelsberg
das fundament wird tief in den boden
hinein getrieben aber der teufelsberg
besteht nicht aus natürlichen gestein er
ist ein trümmerberg errichtet aus 26
millionen kubikmetern schon fast
ausschließlich aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
tief im teufelsberg liegen auch die
reste der wehrtechnischen fakultät die
zur vision des ns architekten albert
speer gehörte nach dem versuch den
rohbau zu sprengen kippte man einfach
darüber
dass die alliierten den trümmerberg nun
zum spionieren nutzen ist den sowjets
ein dorn im auge
die abhöranlage erweist sich als sehr
effektiv in jeder kuppel rotiert eine
parabolantenne mit der man den
funkverkehr der sowjets belauschen kann
so bekommen die westmächte einen
ziemlich guten einblick in das was
hinter den eisernen vorhang passiert
die sogenannten rat dome sind mit
plastikplanen bespannte um die runde
form stabil zu halten herrscht im
inneren der kuppeln überdruck
[Musik]
für die mitarbeiter der station ist das
nicht ungefährlich
[Musik]
es ist erstaunlich dass die kuppel noch
recht gut zu erkennen sind über das
metallgestänge spannte sich eine dünne
plastikhaut und es heißt dass die
mitarbeiter dort vor dem feierabend erst
in eine druckphase mussten sonst hätten
sie vielleicht die taucherkrankheit
bekommen
die sowjets versuchen die abhöranlagen
der westmächte zu blockieren dafür
nutzen sie störsender sogenannte demmer
[Musik]
das gaming gehörte zum standardprogramm
der sorge aber wenn eine fremde anlage
direkt vor der eigenen nase steht kann
man sie kaum sabotieren ohne auch den
eigenen funkverkehr zu stören
der teufelsberg war praktisch ein
gigantischer stinkefinger mitten ins
gesicht der sowjet
[Musik]
die spitze auf dem hügel sammeln
jahrzehntelang informationen über die
pläne und aktivitäten innerhalb des
warschauer paktes
hinweise zu atomwaffen haben höchste
priorität
[Musik]
man erfährt beil ausland schützen eine
menge über den gegner selbst wenn man
seinen code nicht knacken kann den amis
sei klar dass sie abgehört wurden und
die sowjets wussten das genauso
[Musik]
beide seiten bespitzeln sich während des
kalten kriegs ausgiebig mehr als 30
jahre lang nutzen die usa dabei den
standortvorteil in westberlin der insel
im herzen des kommunistischen gegners
[Musik]
mann war praktisch mitten drin sin aus
deutsche oder sowjetische verbände ihre
manöver ablösen jede bewegung jeder
funkverkehr wurde verfolgt es war der
perfekte platz um ihre taktik
auszustellen
den sowjets und ihren verbündeten
gelingt es nicht die lauschangriffe zu
verhindern aber mit dem mauerfall 1989
und mit dem zusammenbruch des warschauer
paktes endet auch die ära des kalten
krieges
in den 90er jahren zieht das us militär
seine leute vom hügel ab die abhör
station wird aufgegeben und verfällt
[Musik]
heute ist die viel station berlin auf
dem teufelsberg zwar eine ruine aber
alles andere als verlassen mit seiner
besonderen atmosphäre zieht der lost
place kreative und freigeister an
dass sich dort heute unter anderem eine
graffiti galerie befindet ist vielleicht
ganz heilsam
was genau auf dem teufelsberg abgehört
wurde ist noch immer streng geheim die
protokolle bleiben bis auf weiteres
unter verschluss der große lauschangriff
gehört allerdings noch lange nicht der
vergangenheit an
[Musik]
nachrichtendienste hören den funk welche
anderer nationen ab dass es nach wie vor
ein wichtiger teil der
geheimdienstarbeit wahrscheinlich spielt
es leuchtet sogar eine größere rolle als
damals
die gesamte ausrüstung wurde aus dem
gebäude entfernt man weiß also nicht
genau was damals alles drin war das ist
immer noch top secret
[Musik]
600 kilometer luftlinie nordwestlich an
der küste dänemarks steht ein leuchtturm
abgelegen und verlassen am meer
[Musik]
das weiße gebäude thront auf der spitze
einer sanddüne
ich denke schicksal bei solchen
sandmassen denkt man eher an die weiten
wüstenlandschaften der sahara als an
dänemark denn
der turm steht gefährlich nah an einer
klippe mit blick über das skagerrak die
meerenge zwischen dänemark norwegen und
schweden
[Musik]
und wie sich dieser verlassenen turner
aus dem sand erhebend ist schon ein
bisschen gruselig
der anblick wird zu seltsam weil es das
was früher einmal drumherum stand nicht
mehr gibt
an der spitze des 23 meter hohen turms
sitzt das glas prisma für das
leuchtfeuer
zu seinen füßen liegen die überreste
ehemaliger
wirtschaftsgebäude
[Musik]
die ganze anlage steht buchstäblich am
abgrund rund 60 meter über den
meeresspiegel
so wie der turm der euro aus der klippe
thront fällt einem auf dass er super
robust geworden er sollte den stärksten
stürmen trotzen warum wurde er also
aufgegeben
[Musik]
während des ersten und zweiten
weltkriegs ist das gac die wichtigste
wasserstraße für die deutsche marine
ihre hauptverbindung von der ostsee zum
offenen meer immer wieder kommt es dort
zu erbitterten sie schlachten
[Musik]
als alte seefahrernation weist dänemark
schon lange wie gefährlich diese
küstenabschnitts auch in friedenszeiten
sein kann im handel mit anderen ländern
zu betreiben müssen die dänen ihre
schiffe durch die tückische meerenge
nutzen
der touristenführer jacob co volk kennt
die geschichte des verwaisten tores
[Musik]
diese gewässer waren für sie fahrer sehr
gefährlich immer wieder brachten stürme
von besten die schiffe in not deswegen
baute man an der küste entlang viele
leuchttürme
[Musik]
die zuständige behörde beschließt an
dieser stelle einen modernen leuchtturm
zu bauen sie nennen ihn europäer knode
für das feuer von nokia knodel
[Musik]
im märz 1899 beginnen die bauarbeiten
aus sicherheitsgründen 200 meter von der
küstenlinie entfernt von der spitze der
60 meter hohen klippe aus soll das
leuchtfeuer weit zu sehen sein und
unzähligen schiffen eine sichere
durchfahrt ermöglichen
[Musik]
diese gewässer sind immer noch stark
befahren und wenn es neblig oder
stürmisch ist braucht man trotz all der
modernen technik auch heute noch
leuchttürme um zu wissen wo das land
anfänger
[Musik]
nach fast zwei jahren bauzeit wird das
leuchtfeuer im dezember 1900 zum ersten
mal angezündet
das gleißend helle licht ist mehr als 40
kilometer weit zu sehen
dafür sorgen die neuartigen fresnel
linsen an der leuchtturm spitze die
scheinwerfer winsen sind außerdem
förmigen stufen aufgebaut und bündeln so
das licht es stammt zunächst von gas und
petroleumlampen später sorgt eine 550
watt glühlampe für die nötige
leuchtkraft
[Musik]
wenn nur der sand nicht wäre immer
wieder geraten die feinen körner ins
getriebe
aber wie sich bald herausstellt ist das
noch das kleinste problem
[Musik]
als der leuchtturm gebaut wurde lange
200 meter von der küste entfernt und 60
meter über dem meeresspiegel
einige kilometer südlich war eine
sanddüne aber eine ganz besondere
objekte ist eine der größten wanderdünen
europas sie bewegt sich pro jahr etwa
zehn meter in richtung nordosten
seit ende des 16 jahrhunderts haben sich
millionen kubikmeter sand über die
nordspitze von dänemark geschoben
[Musik]
da oben gibt es also eine art
schleichenden sand zunahme der langsam
aber stetig die küste überrollt
sanddünen haben meist einen langen hang
über die in der wind fegte und zur kampf
spitze hin immer mehr sand aufläuft auf
der windschatten seite fällt der sand
dann steil ab so belegt sich die dünen
langsam stück für stück vorwärts und
weil man den wind nicht aufhalten kann
kann man eine wanderdüne auch nicht
stoppt
die dünne es zwar schon seit
jahrhunderten unterwegs aber als der
leuchtturm gebaut wurden gab es keine
anzeichen dass der sand einmal dort
landen würden
anfangs los das leuchtfeuer von objekten
der schiffe zuverlässig durch nebel und
dunkelheit vorbei an den gefährlichen
untiefen des skagerrak
aber in den 1920 er jahren zeigt sich
zum entsetzen der ingenieure dass die
wanderbühne dem leuchtturm gefährlich
nahe auf die pelle rückt
sie versuchten die naturgewalten zu
überlisten und den sand durch barrieren
aufzuhalten
die sorgten aber nur dafür dass sich der
sand staute und im endeffekt noch höher
auftürmte die bühne wurde immer größer
man hatte das problem also noch
verschlimmert
[Musik]
die steilküste auf der der leuchtturm
steht wirkt wie eine rampe der sand wird
im schneckentempo darüber geschoben
[Musik]
der sand wurde über die klippe geblasen
und verschluckte nach und nach die
häuser rund um den objekten
er verteilte sich um den leuchtturm
herum und die düne wuchs immer mehr in
die höhe
inzwischen ist die bühne weitergezogen
aber in den 50er jahren ragt sie so hoch
dass man das leuchtfeuer von roger kluge
vom meer aus nicht länger sehen kann der
leuchtturm liegt versteckt in einer
sandkuhle
als letztes mittel haben sie versucht
den sand rund um den leuchtturm einfach
weg zu schicken aber sie müssen schon
damals gewusst habe dass sie diesen
kampf gegen die natur nicht gewinnen
konnte
[Musik]
1968 geben sich die betreiber
schließlich geschlagen das leuchtfeuer
von rupp diagnose erwischt für immer
der turm und die gebäude um ihn herum
werden zu einem museum zum sand treiben
umgebaut ironischerweise bedeutet das
forschungsobjekt selbst das ende für das
museum
unaufhaltsamen schieden sich die
sandmassen über die gebäude
2002 wird das museum geschlossen der
sand hat endgültig gewonnen
[Musik]
der leuchtturm von objekt mode bleibt
aber auch danach eine beliebte
touristenattraktion
tausende besucher erklimmen jedes jahr
die riesenbühne umhin zu bestaunen
solange es noch geht
denn der wind der die löhne über das
land treibt nagt auch an der kippe auf
der der turm steht
die küstenlinie kommt gefährlich nahe in
ein paar jahren wird es hier keinen
leuchtturm mehr geben
die wanderbühne hat das leuchtfeuer von
rub jak nutzlos gemacht jetzt steht der
turm selbst auf der kippe
damit das wahrzeichen der region nicht
ins meer stürzt plant die gemeinde den
leuchtturm weiter ins landesinnere zu
verlegen
vor über 100 jahren bauten die
ingenieure einen robusten turm der den
rauen elementen an der küste trotzen
sollte aber sie haben unterschätzt wie
sehr der wind die landschaft verändern
würde
[Musik]
mutter natur erinnert uns ständig daran
wer das letzte wort hat
[Musik]
sie zählten zum fortschrittlichsten was
ingenieurs und baukunst zu bieten hatten
heute sind ihre ruinen nur noch ein echo
der geschichte manche sind überbleibsel
von krieg und krisen andere erinnern uns
daran wie kühlen der mensch seine umwelt
formt
[Musik]